au tribunal de bobigny les magistrats
n'en peuvent plus beaucoup de dossiers
sont classés sans suite dans nos
commissariats on nous a annoncé
prochainement un tiers seraient fermées
la nuit
pour plus d'efficacité défense de rire
en matière d'éducation dans nos collèges
on découvre qu'en considérant les heures
effectuées devant élèves le mieux doté
des collèges de seine saint denis est
moins bien doté que le moins bien dotées
des collèges parisiens
tout le monde sait cela monsieur le
ministre il y a eu deux mille sept cent
visites ministérielles en disant
seine-saint-denis une par jour
qui peut dire qu'ils ignorent cela alors
ça ne date pas d'hier
monsieur le ministre mais la question
qu'est-ce qu'on qu'est ce que vous
entendez faire pour donner un peu de
sens hautes herbes d'égalité
républicaine dans ce département
merci dans le domaine de l'éducation
nationale le département bénéficiera à
la rentrée prochaine de 4 166 postes
supplémentaires pour le seul premier
degré et il bénéficiera du dédoublement
des classes
ma collègue garde des sceaux est
également pleinement mobilisés pour
améliorer la situation au tribunal de
grande instance de bobigny elle s'est
engagée à pourvoir l'ensemble des postes
de magistrats et de fonctionnaires dès
septembre 2018 et affecter un certain
nombre de magistrats en surnom le 22 mai
dernier
beaucoup d'élus de seine saint denis met
d'ailleurs en banlieue se sont sentis
mitre méprisé par certains propos du
président de la république qui pointait
du doigt et élus locaux de banlieue les
renvoyant d'un revers de main comme jean
louis borloo mais quand la politique de
droit commun n'est pas au niveau
comment voulez vous que la politique de
la ville donne des résultats monsieur le
ministre
alors nous ne sommes pas des citoyens de
seconde zone nous ne sommes pas là pour
être visité nous voulons effectivement
de l'action nous y avons droit comme
partout en france
ma question porte sur l'abaissement de
100 % à 10 % du pourcentage de logements
accessibles aux personnes handicapées
dans la construction neuve telle que
votée récemment l'assemblée nationale
dans le cadre de la loi est lent il y
avait déjà beaucoup trop de dérogations
mais avec cette disposition de la loi
est lent les huit cent mille personnes
en situation de handicap sans même
compter les enfants ni les personnes
vieillissantes en perte d'autonomie ne
pourrait plus accéder qu'à quelques
milliers de logements neufs chaque année
votre loi remet en cause le principe de
l'accessibilité universelle une grave
régression sociale un recul gigantesque
selon les associations en réalité vous
céder au lobby des promoteurs
immobiliers qui réclamait cette mesure
il ne s'agit pas dans les propositions
de textes de la loi l enquête
actuellement débattu à l'assemblée
nationale qui reviendra devant vous de
revenir en arrière sur ce principe
d'accessibilité mais nous passons du
100% adapté hausse en bourse en
adaptable qu'est-ce que cela signifie
ça signifie de faire en sorte que les
freins que de nombreux maires ont connu
et certains dans cet hémicycle le savent
bien qui font qu'au nom d'un aménagement
global souvent l'opération pouvait ne
pas se faire ça signifie qu'au fond le
logement doit répondre aux besoins de
chacun et doit l'accompagner tout au
long de sa vie et cela n'empêche en rien
une personne à mobilité réduite de
rendre visite à quelqu'un dans son
appartement car toutes les parties
communes vont rester accessible comme le
séjour comme les toilettes des
appartements mais il est essentiel et le
temps du décret viendra pour définir
cela que cette question de
l'adaptabilité soit défini en prenant en
compte les besoins les demandes et en
particulier des asus des associations
qui accompagnent les personnes et le
combat des personnes en situation de
handicap
suite
oui